hello everyone happy Mother's Day by the
time you guys are watching this at home
I'm gonna be celebrating my first
Mother's Day I'm obviously trying to
shoot this a little bit ahead of time
because I still have a baby on board so
I can enjoy it those first few weeks
with my baby
but today in celebration of the big
Mother's Day I wanted to share a few
thoughts on motherhood with you so every
Mother's Day before this has always been
about celebrating my mom and I want to
of course continue that because my mom's
the best I have had such a great
relationship with my mom she's been such
a good role model for me she's like the
mom mom she is like a Martha Stewart but
like not a convict but also is just like
has been such a great career woman so
for me watching her own her own business
start her own business in a few times
actually has been so inspiring to me all
the while being like so hands-on as a
mom she did everything for us growing up
so I'm just hoping that of course I can
do the same for my little one while
still inspiring hopefully some kind of
some kind of drive and ambition for
whatever they want to do
so for those of you guys who are
followers of my blog you might know that
this was not an easy road for me I am
considered one in the one in eight
couples who suffer from infertility and
for that reason this is has been an IVF
baby so we had to undergo a lot in order
to to get where we are today so lots of
needles
lots of appointments and it's lots of
stress really but obviously that means
that I'm so grateful for the blessing
that I have my recognize that so many
other couples and families and and women
have have gone through it all and even
more and still do not have that baby in
their arms so I'm I just am so grateful
and so excited that to be celebrating
this Mother's Day with with you
so I think what's hard is when you're
when you're struggling with infertility
for somebody to say to you oh you know
don't worry about it it'll happen when
it's meant to happen
keep fighting or to say you know what's
meant to be will be like somebody's hate
when people say what's meant to be will
be because when you're in it that can be
some of the most frustrating words to
hear because it's all you're thinking
about it's all you want and someone's
telling you that you know it's it's it's
it's left of someone else's to decide or
something like that so I refrain from
telling people that even though you know
a lot people think that that's
comforting to know that it's you know
it's it's in some bigger bigger plan
yeah because we like to have control
over everything especially something
that's so you know seemingly so in
important integral to our role as women
and so I try I try not to to use that
kind of language with women who are
struggling with infertility because I
know how frustrating that can be however
I I think all we can do is keep you know
keep positive keep busy recognize all
the other blessings that we have you
have in your life there's so much to be
grateful for I know for me and my
infertility journey just feel just
understanding my own my own blessings
that I have a supportive husband and
family I have the means to be able to
afford this treatment I you know there
are so many other things that could have
been not in my favor and were so just
acknowledging all the small things that
that you do have in your life that are
fantastic
whether or not you end up with with a
child that is yours just just knowing
that there are other things to to move
forward and to look forward to is really
a good step
I think if I wanted to say something to
my future baby especially as they as
they get older enough to understand what
I was saying my hope would be that they
are able to find their own happiness
whatever that may be and that's not an
easy road for a lot of people I believe
in hard work and I think that those are
some things that my own family really
instilled in me and the importance of
working hard for something that you're
passionate about something that you
really believe in
so finding in and working towards that
happiness whatever that that means for
them is really all that matters to me if
somebody's happy doing doing something
that I wouldn't want to do then to me
that's that's great and there's nothing
more than I could that I could want for
my child so I think dream big I did and
it's it's definitely being a harder Road
but a more fulfilling one so I think
yeah just just reach reach high you've
got to be [ __ ] good to me
no I don't know what parents want for
their kids
well I'm Jewish it is the the Jewish
mother the stereotypical Jewish mother
way to to think that oh they you just
want your kids to be a doctor or a
lawyer but the reality is I I don't
really care what do you want to do
professionally I don't care who you want
to marry I don't care if it's in the
faith outside the faith I don't care
where they live or where they come from
but I don't care if you don't marry at
all it really whatever is is going to
make you light up is is the most
important thing to me as a parent
and I will do whatever I have to do to
support you everything I think that the
hardest things from Burmese as someone
who's so type a and such a perfectionist
and you know a worrier I'm worried about
worrying for the rest of my life
you know if pregnancy alone was so so
stressful because I felt like I had so
much riding on it I spent a year before
getting pregnant just you know my whole
life was based around trying to get
pregnant and then after that now my
whole pregnancy is being worrying about
this pregnancy going well and now I have
to worry that the rest of my life is
gonna be spent worrying about my baby
and and everything else that happens in
their life so certainly I'm certainly
worried about about never feeling at
ease again also because I am an
entrepreneur and I own in my own
business I am worried about trying to
find that balance that so many of us
moms have a hard time finding I love my
job I love what I do I mean how could I
not I get to share such fun adventures
and recipes and and I get to dance
around in a [ __ ] gold onesie every
day for you guys so it's pretty amazing
but I get to to do everyday but I'm also
acknowledging that I'm sure every day
with you is going to be just as good if
not better and it's going to be so hard
for me to be able to find that balance
where I feel fulfilled as as you know as
a just as a human being but also as
filling the most important role which is
your mom so I think that that
my lifelong struggles is how do I find
peace with myself being just good enough
at both of them what am I say about I'm
excited about everything I'm excited to
have our own feel like our little our
little family's more complete I'm
excited to see you grow up with poppy as
your big sister I'm excited to share you
with all of our family who is so excited
to meet you you know part of being a mom
of course is for me is you know I'm I'm
more than excited for to have that
experience with you but it's also so
nice to be able to give something to my
parents and my in-laws as like the
greatest gift ever I mean being a
grandparent I'm sure is best because you
get to have that love but you don't have
to have to take it home and and feed it
at the end of the day so it seems like a
pretty awesome deal and something that
I'm so happy that I can I could give I'm
excited to go on trips with you and and
share exciting experiences with you that
I've only really ever gotten to
experience myself or with my husband and
I just can't wait to do it all and and
to watch you grow in every stage and be
surprised and amazed and at all and of
course to all of you viewers I'm so
excited to bring you into this world
with me I'm sure as parents we can all
learn so much from each other and I'm
excited to kind of enter a new realm
obviously I'm still gonna be doing tons
of food and nutrition based content
because that is my passion
but as they enter this new chapter in my
life I'm also gonna be doing a lot more
mom content so there's give me that
whole world to explore as well I can't
wait to take you guys all along with me
for this journey so I hope you have a
fantastic Mother's Day whether you are
celebrating yourself or you're
celebrating someone that you love your
mother your mother-in-law your
grandmother your sister all of the good
people in the world all the moms all the
women who are just working so hard if
you guys like this video please be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your number one piece
of mom advice for me definitely will
help me out also subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
I'm glad we did this at the end of the
Beggs Omega so ruined
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]